there's nothing like being creatively
aligned with a group of people and
watching what that produces
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
amia wolf started ten years ago as an
art collective it was really just a
space that we could express ourselves in
its a maximal kaleidoscopic
conglomeration of ideas and that's what
we've always been really good at is
setting the ego aside letting go of who
has the idea and coming up with the best
idea ten of us came together we'd put in
a hundred dollars a month we rented a
900 square foot space we were making art
we were writing theater starting bands
and playing music together it was the
Wild West of creativity is what it was
it's about like not waiting for
something else outside of your control
to give you permission to do we couldn't
continue to sustain this large group of
people on these sort of free shows that
were just a passion project when we had
to actually start thinking about
business we thought to ourselves what
are we most comparable to the stuff we
were making was for the kid inside of us
that wanted to live inside of a magical
world and so then it naturally
translated to kids and we basically
looked at children's museums and it
wasn't a compromise really in fact we
think it's awesome
[Music]
it's more than just an art exhibition
it's a place for people to gather
[Music]
we need more people bringing creative
communities to the forefront and so when
hyundai comes along and is like yes this
is valuable that's awesome our only hope
is alternative creative spaces if we
want to keep America a place that is
culturally rich the DIY fund is an
initiative to help underground DIY art
collectives to continue to exist I want
me I'll have to end up being something
that helps people do the thing that they
want to do
the exhibition here in Santa Fe has
become a like cultural hub we're
building 80,000 square feet in Denver
we're building 50,000 square feet in
Vegas and we want to continue the art
collective ethos that means like working
with artists and creatives of that city
that we're moving to you know when you
bring a bunch of people who are really
passionate about something together that
builds community you know luckily we
found a a group of people that were very
passionate about creating an art and
self-expression the reason that we do
this has stayed consistent trying to do
some small thing that we feel like is
going to leave a positive mark on our
world
[Music]